[Music]
you're doing it wrong news submitted by
right on right on right on your bought a
fake tuberculosis diagnosis gnosis
online so he could take a longer
vacation I was so happy that I got said
tuberculosis correctly that I [ __ ] up
diagnosis the teacher bought a fake
tuberculosis diagnosis online as hard as
that as an awful so he could take a
longer vacation who found out about this
what dark jaded soul was like I bet
that's not a real tuberculosis diagnosed
he actually had to rat on himself
what because this story is funny all
right so this english teacher at a
private school in china's mongolia area
he was forced to make a public apology
because after china's national day
vacation he wanted to expand extend that
vacation so he went online he paid 470
yuan which is about sixty seven dollars
for a fake chest scan and a doctor's
diagnosis on the internet that's how
easy it isn't charlie a fake [ __ ] yeah
you're surprised I mean they sense
there's so many other things but you can
give free to break the listen diagnosis
do you know that there's Chanel bags
aren't really there no weights of the
tuberculosis diagnosis is real it's a
real like a real chest scan a real
diagnosis our doctors know or whatever
and so he he picked like the disease I
picked was tuberculosis which is very
serious and highly contagious
it's a pulmonary disease he was just
like yeah give me that one yeah could
have picked the cold or something yeah
he [ __ ] up tetanus I would have done
touch you weren't gonna let him go back
to school to tease so because of the
fact that TV is so contagious and it's
potentially life-threatening the entire
school was forced to pay medical
checkups for all of the students
this teacher and so they had to make
sure that they didn't get the disease
but they found out that two of the
students tested positive for TB oh and
then so so again he went online
he paid another three hundred and
fifteen yuan which is about forty five
dollars for another fake diagnosis which
showed that he no longer had the disease
found the cheaper site but he should
test himself for real because like if he
might he might have it if two kids
tested positive but then parents and
like administered people they didn't
believe him because in order to cure TB
it takes months of antibiotics to cure
and so they forced him to undergo a
third testing at a hospital a real test
a real test which showed that he had
never had TB because t v-- leaves
physical marks in your lungs and so the
previous x-rays it did show that you
know he had it so his actual x-rays
didn't show he even had it in the first
place so now that he was cornered he had
to he had to fess up and tell you that
he lied and so he was trying to just
extend his vacation so he ended up
issuing an apology but yeah damn I'd be
like see this is why one in a second
opinion cuz yeah I wasn't sure Wow yeah
right you got a double triple quadruple
down yeah wait what about the kids
though didn't he save them didn't he
help them true that's a good way to look
at it when they found out that when
they're coughing up blood
Leedy yeah oh I need a hospital or is
their vaccination don't we do TV action
I feel like yeah I don't like it cuz
like we don't have tuberculosis that's
true all right thing we do vaccinations
I know I just know TB is what doc
holliday had yeah oh hell yeah I mean I
love that yeah yeah and tombstone yeah
cuz you're just coughing up blood and
you just heart breathe you're sweating
all the time that's amazing you're just
like give me whatever well there was the
cheapest one I know I don't know then
you have to pay a lot more I want to
check out this site where has all these
fake disease down
and you get to see what the prices are
maybe counselors like 300 bucks
is that optically in the middle yeah
yeah he's like TVs 80 so they haven't
reported whether or not he's like he
still has his job or if he actually did
get his extended vacation or if you got
a thank-you from two kids you did get an
extended vacation
I don't know have you guys ever gotten
tested for TB no I did get pneumonia and
second grade or first grade and I
remember I had to be in the hospital for
a week and it was pretty tight because
uh my dad kept bringing me Big Macs
every day and then even though the
doctor said no dairy so I would just eat
the big man or just keep throwing up so
I threw up like the whole week but it
was so awesome
I had a thing like where I broke out
everywhere and I went to the
dermatologist and he said there was no
way to tell the difference between a
kadai between pityriasis which is what
it ended up being or I can't run for his
scabies or syphilis it was one of those
two it was like you either had this
crazy STD or it's pityriasis and I'll go
in three weeks so we had to wait for
three weeks
not knowing just I know it was in a
serious relationship at that time and I
was like you cheat on me what could you
two be so they can't test your blood for
someone um I feel like the so it was
it's costly so it's like if you wait
three weeks and it doesn't go away then
you should probably get tested for it
but if you wait three weeks and it goes
away then it's the first one that's the
pityriasis doctor you going to STD
testing czar like free and preventive
mmm I don't know um no it wasn't it
wasn't free and and I just went to the
gyno and STD testing was not free maybe
it depends on your health insurance true
but yeah it was just basically like a to
take a blood test with it's like you
should wait three weeks first so is it
psoriasis and pure ice and there are
those two different ones yes this is
like a skin thing no they're both skin
things but pityriasis is like something
that
comes and goes what it sounds like it
should be on your foot but it's pretty
gnarly cuz so so they dip the thing that
looks the same is like there's a there's
a Harold scar a Harold mark that comes
in first so this is like this big mark
that was on my boob like it was just
like this big like huge like scaly patch
that appeared on my boob one day and it
was like this 2-inch like huge thing and
I was like what the [ __ ] is this and it
just kept growing and then you have
these like little scaly patches that
look like the big one but they're like
little ones all over you grayscale yeah
yeah basically yeah and because they
don't look like mosquito bites were like
kind of dry and scaly putting more
lotion on it yeah
does it work a work how to make it look
like more like normal skin yeah no it
just stays scaly it sounds like you're
turning into one of those brick people
in Game of Thrones yeah that's what she
just said
that's what those are called yeah you
took home a dad um er it's not a joke it
sounded like that I think I got ringworm
from a teeny bit once oh [ __ ] well what
else would you get right here was it
like a circular lumpy thing that's
ringworm I never got a diagnose or their
other bumps too cuz it like started like
that right here dude I had Taco Bell's
st nachos one time years ago when they
came out with the zesty nachos
it was bomb but dude I had a full-blown
allergic reaction to it I met Lord
anything known to man I've been tested
multiple times
I'm not mad you know you were allergic
there's not allergic reaction the doctor
diagnosed me with an allergic reaction
brezza we can't find what you're
allergic you're allergic to milk you
[ __ ] dumbass no I'm not you stupid
dumb [ __ ] you said nothing known to man
this this I'm not allergic you little
piece of cheese and he like throws up
for days
no I don't
gonna be well never done true I am not
allergic to anything that's the problem
is that they couldn't find whatever the
[ __ ] was in this I don't think is of the
earth
what were your symptoms so I had crazy
rashes all over and then I had a crazy
temperature and uh yeah I had to go to
the house and there's this was because
of the nachos I ain't talked about zesty
nachos 30 minutes later what you can
handle this well obviously not
they don't make them anymore well the
time old me they a lot of people did get
hospitalized for the cyst I think they
ran out of whatever were their place
before or after they changed their
recipe because it used to be like 75%
oat all the beef used to be 7% oats
uh-huh which I'm like they had people
found out people loved finding about
what's in [ __ ] and so now it's more
beefy and then people ruin it for all of
us I remember gonna find out what's in
[ __ ] couple years ago I think it was a
year ago people were pissed because
they're like Subway's chickens not real
chicken and I'm like no [ __ ] like who
the [ __ ] thinks that's real chicken they
have the burn marks painted on there
yeah it looks like fake chicken
yeah like objectively I had so many
diseases not diseases but things that
look like other things I think I've
talked about it before but like I had
yeah cuz I thought talking about
costochondritis were like it could
either be a heart attack true or it
could be this really benign thing Costco
con right there we gotta kind of like am
i infected what is this that's cool we
have it in you to actually research
because some [ __ ] happens to me I'm like
I know I could probably have cancer and
might die oh well like whatever like
weird-looking ovary that's do it like it
actually hurts right now sometimes throw
it like I still haven't figured it out
because I don't like you still haven't
checked no no so I'm saying I still
haven't figured out when in the time of
the month is it actually hurt like I
haven't noticed if it's like before my
period after a period during ovulation I
don't know it's like random right but I
have gone to checked where they do
like an ultrasound and they look at my
ovary and they just said like you just
have a lot of eggs in that over you know
like but are you sure it's like teeming
full of eggs yeah they said that like
next time most likely they're like
you're latina you only have one kid oh
you got a stockpile of eggs I know they
said like I think most likely came from
my right ovary pregnant again and they
go to the wrong fallopian tube it's like
there's nothing here cuz they're all
over here it's like well sorry [ __ ]
weird that you know exactly where Isaac
came from I know I don't is that's so
dope though you can point to it be like
mother [ __ ] you paper right here it's
dope his case you know which side of
come on too
[Music]